we're now joined by the leader of the
Liberal Democrats Joe Swenson thank you
very much for being with us ahead this
morning Jack good to be with you sit now
we heard from Boris Johnson a little bit
earlier in the show and he was pretty
clear that he places the blame for the
fact we hadn't left that uu squarely at
the door of parliament he says Parlin
was going to rope-a-dope as forcing more
extensions which means businesses can't
plan families can't plan he is why isn't
he it's Parliament who thought it
through watered that leaving he's wrong
he's the Prime Minister he's the one
who's responsible he wanted this job for
so long and he was prepared to say
whatever he felt he should say in order
to get that job without giving any real
thought to what he would do so he made a
stupid promise
that do or die that we would be open the
31st of October without actually
planning how to do that he then became
Prime Minister didn't actually try and
negotiate a deal until the very last
minute I mean like Boris Johnson's only
got himself to blame for the fact that
he hasn't been able to keep the promise
that he should never have made it I
didn't he he negotiated a deal he put to
Parliament he's done everything he's
been Parliament who thought two months
mucking about to stop right so anyway I
do want to stop break this donut I do
want to stop breaks it but he spent two
months mucking about without even
negotiating a new deal it was only when
Parliament said very clearly that we
would not enable No Deal that he even
bothered trying to get a deal and that
shouldn't have been news to him if he'd
been paying attention
he might have realized that Parliament
wasn't in favor of a new deal breaks it
so frankly he's only got himself to
blame and we now have the opportunity to
stop brexit in this general election the
Liberal Democrats are clearly the
strongest biggest party of remain and we
know there are millions of people out
there who want us to end this chaos stop
brexit and get on with making people's
lives better well let's talk about this
election shall we and because in the
Sunday Times today the reports that
those have remain alliance we're like Oh
Murray the Lib Dems and the Greens
working together in up to 60 seats we're
effectively two of the three parties
stand aside to give the other a better
shot is that right so the specifics of
announcements where we may
in due course but it's well understood
that these discussions have been taking
place six is sixty seats in hydrogen I
wouldn't necessarily assume that the
numbers are accurate but we've been
having those discussions because there
are people in those different parties
these are parties that want to stop
brexit and remain in the European Union
and we found that in the Brecon and
rather shibai election at the beginning
of august we had a successful example of
where applied camry and the green party
didn't feel candidates they stood side
by side with the Liberal Democrat James
Dodds and we were able to win that seat
in a return to Parliament an MP who
would campaign enthusiastically to
remain and that's what happened so we're
in those discussions and announcements
will be forthcoming I mean you're
shouting down the idea of 60 seats and
when we're talking dozens of seats I'm
just trying cuz obviously it's very
different isn't if you're just talking
about a small handful if you're talking
about a large bloc that could actually
impact the result of an election so I
think it's fair to say that in the vast
majority of constituencies the party of
remain that is going to be best placed
to win that seat would be the Liberal
Democrats but it's not universally the
case there will be some seats in Wales
where it might be applied curry and
there might be a small number of seats
where it's the Green Party and of course
we should work constructing
constructively with those other parties
to further our ultimate goal which is
protecting our place in the European
Union so that we can have a better
future what I don't understand is if you
really are determined to try and protect
our place in the European Union as you
put it
why have you ruled out working with
Jeremy Corbyn labour had promised a
second referendum I know you don't like
him very much
no it's clearly perhaps the easiest and
simplest route to getting a second
referendum that could mean - talking
back so I mean I certainly find the way
in which he's refused to tackle
anti-semitism in his own party shocking
and wrong but this is not about my
personal view of Jeremy Corbyn this is
about what he is doing on the issue of
remaining in the European Union oh wait
a second I mean we saw her a sort of
referendum according to Rebecca long
Bailey I mean that that was a painful to
watch when you asked her and you asked
her again what would labour do in that
referendum would you can paint
will remain they cannot answer the
question is irrelevant
babysitting referendum it is perhaps
your your best chance of getting what
you want would to sustain that you it is
not irrelevant to recognize that the
Labour leadership do not even know even
now three and a half years after that
2016 referendum they do not even know
whether they want to remain or leave
nineteen Labour MPs voted for Boris
Johnson's bad brexit deal that will
drive a coach horses through workers
rights and environmental protections it
will be bad for our economy in our NHS
and yet nineteen Labour MPs vote for
that nineteen of how many who didn't
vote the other way but 1919 it made the
difference Boris Johnson got his second
reading because of Labour MPs and their
I hear Labour's say that they want to
try and have a jobs first Briggs that
Briggs that they'll protect the reality
is breaks it will be bad for jobs it
would be bad for workers rights it will
be bad for the economy it is not
possible what they are arguing they want
breaks it will be bad for our country
that's why Liberal Democrats want to
stop breaks it now I'm keen to talk to
you about the debates as well I know
that many in your party have been
pointing to the fact that you're the
female leader of a major party you
haven't been invited to this first
debate surely the reason you have been
invited is because the two people have
been asked at the tea people whom you've
got the most likely chance of being the
next prime minister I'm a candidate to
be Prime Minister in this election and
frankly when you look at the way Boris
Johnson and Jeremy Corbyn are carrying
on I think I could do a better job than
either of them if you look at the 2010
election and the run-up to that election
Liberal Democrats were pulling around a
similar amount than we are now actually
were no much closer to the other parties
in terms of the pull ratings and in that
election we had Gordon Brown David
Cameron and Nick Clegg spot the
difference well I mean frankly you've
got a suggestion from a broadcaster that
it will be to chaps chatting about how
they're going to leave the European
Union leaving out the voice from
millions of remain errs who want to stop
breaks it and stay in the EU and yeah
happen to be a woman well you know isn't
isn't that in
because when it was nick clegg there was
no problem with him being in the debates
but look at the number of MPs I mean the
labour the Conservatives have a combined
total of 542 MPs the Lib Dems have 20
sure but as I say if you look at the
comparison to 2010 right you had Liberal
Democrats still had far fewer MPs than
the other parties but Nick Clegg was
okay to be in those debates I mean
frankly either it's sexist or they're
scared or maybe it's a bit of both and I
should be there as the voice for the
millions of people in this country who
want to remain it is ridiculous to have
a debate where on the biggest issue
facing our country you have an entire
side of that debate unrepresented and if
there was an independence debate
Commission something that Sky News is
called for then participation would be
decided independently without via good
idea well I certainly think that that
would that would make much more sense
because what you've got is two blokes
stitching up about what they're prepared
to do and as I say they looks like
they're running scared frankly okay now
well I've got you there's one final
thing I want to talk to you about and
that is some of the campaign literature
that your party has been pumping out and
you've got a bit of a reputation for
doing this in the past as well now I
just wanna have a look at this this is
North East Somerset the Liberal
Democrats in North East Somerset Liberal
Democrat campaign literature a results
of a survey done in the constituency of
Jacob Riis mark you would think this was
a two horse race went you between the
Conservatives on 38% and live the Lib
Dems on 32% until you look at the very
very tiny small print at the bottom
which says the question was imagine that
the result in your constituency was
expected to be very close between the
conservative and Liberal Democrat
candidates and none of the other parties
were competitive in this scenario which
party would you vote for and I just want
to show the last result from this
constituency at the last election which
hopefully we should be able to bring up
now which shows that actually the
Conservatives won 53 percent and labour
won 34 percent the Lib Dems on 8.3 I
mean this is entirely misleading isn't
it
I think partisan well if politics has
changed significantly since the 2017
election no this isn't it has look in
mail even at last the last national
elections that we had in this country
the Liberal Democrats beat both the
Conservative Party and the late
party that is the first time that's
happened for a hundred years something
very different
why don't you show the gnashing snow I
mean that is a that is my it was a
specific pool in that particular sea and
we've labeled what the question was
clearly and and you know and in the
local elections I mean in that
constituency Jacob Riis Nagano has a
liberal Democrat councilor right so the
Liberal Democrats have been making
progress and winning in that area and
part of the reason for that is that the
people who voted labour in 2017 because
they thought that labour would stand up
to remain in the EU have been bitterly
disappointed and they know that no is
the Liberal Democrats who are the place
to vote for if you want to stop breaks
it how can you criticize some of the
stuff that was said in the EU election
campaign when you are pumping out things
that misleading as well I mean this is
like the 350 million pounds on the side
of a past look I mean we've said exactly
what the question is you know it's
labeled on there what the question is
that it that it relates to so so anybody
there's interested in looking at it can
read what that question is if you talk
about that figure on the side of a bus
that's something which you know just
bore no resemblance whatsoever to
reality and it wasn't calculated in a
way that made sense so it's entirely
different we're out of time J Swenson
thank you very much for you on the
program today